la STM doit trouver
77,7 millions de dollars pour balancer
son budget de 1,7 milliards pour 2023 et
demande l'aide de Québec soyons clairs
avec plus d'ajustement que ce qu'on
propose on change de niveau de service
la STM pour le 20% qui reste certains
services d'autobus seront revus pour
diminuer la fréquence des véhicules qui
circulent vide ou en ajouter sur les
trajets plus achalandés la STM dit ne
pas vouloir toucher aux lignes d'autobus
dont les passages sont au 30 minutes ni
aux services dans les quartiers
industriels toutefois le temps d'attente
sur les kills métro changera sur
certaines lignes aux heures de pointe
les rames de métro passeront à un
intervalle de 2 minutes 45 secondes au
lieu de 2 minutes 15 secondes sur la
ligne verte et les périodes de pointe où
le service est plus rapide seront
diminués de quelques minutes sur la
ligne orange si le métro est passe moins
souvent l'autobus aussi ça me gêne
beaucoup c'est un peu dommage pour les
personnes qui doivent reposer là-dessus
pour leur déplacement des gens qui vont
vouloir voyager en
certainement pas à plus d'accès d'heures
la STM assure que l'offre sera similaire
à 2022 mais concède qu'elle n'a plus de
marge de manœuvre des réductions légères
mais quand même des réductions de
service on
[Musique]